taiwan walker seven and seven at one
point in mid-june he was six and two
with an era of 2.12 through his first
dozen starts
made the all-star team pitched an inning
in the game in colorado gave up a home
run to the raise mike zenino and since
the all-star game
he's 0-4 era nearly 10 and 10 home runs
allowed in five post-all-star game
starts
so so walker right here great signing by
the mets he's he's created his value
here it's been a good move it's been
nice to have him healthy all season he's
coming out here what is what i see from
here is that is that four-seam sinker
split mix slider curve ball has been
extremely effective for him trey turner
stands in
he strikes turner out to start this
outing
and there's that fast ball up in the
zone that i was speaking of he's
beginning his lightest strikeouts on his
fastball he's going to be dependent on
that tonight max muncie stands in
muncie lifts a pop-up on the infield
[Applause]
vr the shortstop clutches it
his 01 to smith
bounce towards short vr fields it and
puts an end to a one two three top of
the first
walker bueller comes in at 12 and two
his era of 2.13 leads all major league
starters jacob degram on the injured
list still
for the mets and his time of return is a
big question mark here is jeff mcneil in
his fourth big league season with a
career batting average of 308
hits this one hard ordinarily that would
be through the middle but with the shift
on they get him nimmo advances to second
base fortunately the shift right there
took the double play away that top five
five four out of five guys left-handed
bats trying to make things happen
against bueller
last night was pete alonso bobblehead
night and they filled just about every
seat
at shortstop seeger backhands
looks nimo back to second and throws
alonso out so now dominic smith not in
the lineup last night against darius
smith rolls one to the right side and
from the edge of the outfield grass
he's thrown out by turner no runs no
hits a walk and a man is left no score
after one at city field bottom of the
second michael conforto to face walker
bueller the 2-2 pitch curve ball got him
that's why you got to get him early you
get behind and count on him he's lights
out
that's how good he is he can miss right
down the middle and still have you
completely off balance that's impressive
brings up jd davis
who checks in at 308.
oh starts the second with a pair of
strikeouts and here's jeff mcneal with
two out and nobody on
another chance for muncie and again he
takes it himself
quick third inning for walker mueller
five strikeouts for him now
as he takes care of will smith and up
comes seeger who fanned in the second
bouncing ball another chance for mcneal
and that is that
obviously what jumps out there have been
some walks there has not been a hit for
either side here's one jolted to deep
right field this ball is back near the
wall and gone into the bullpen
mckinney made an effort but he couldn't
pull it back
and for conforto first hit of the game
eighth home run of the season first run
of the game
one-nothing mets
they got they got the crowd up out here
in city field
starting to feel the energy around here
people people standing on their feet now
bottom of the fifth at city field bottom
of the order for the mets against walker
bueller jonathan vr how to walk in the
second that's nice though let's see if
he can get him a bag of day
leadoff hit for vr
well he manages to run the count out to
three and two
he strikes out second in the inning six
in the game for walker bueller that's
two times the pitchers haven't been able
to get the butt down bueller ran into
the same situation
instead he pops him into shallow left
center field
three players converge it's bellinger
who'll take it now runs ahead a man is
left entering the six taiwan walker has
allowed but one base runner the guy
standing at the plate now billy mckinney
who walked in the third
and finally after several foul balls
mckinney strikes out the seventh
strikeout for taiwan walker so here's
trey turner who is struck out and fly
down
at third base davis there's one can they
turn it
they do that's nice great play davis
they turned it on turner and what did i
say
it becomes serious after six and walker
has not allowed a hit through six
conforto's home run in the fourth
is the difference right now dominic
smith at first with two out
and conforto strikes out that's eight
through six innings of work for bueller
smith is left at first and after six
one nothing new york this is walker's
ninth year in the big leagues first five
with the mariners then three with the
d-backs a very short stay with the blue
jays this is first season with the
mats in center field
nemo in pursuit
smith also there and it's nimmo the
centerfielder who makes the catch it's
one thing to have a plan and it's
another to go out there and be able to
execute it and he is executing to
perfection tonight
a drive to deep left center field there
goes the no-hitter there goes the
shutout there goes the lead
and it's that man again will smith his
17th of the season his second and two
nights in this series
and that was that backup slider which
normally that backup slider is effective
but right there will smith was ready for
it able to get the barrel out on it and
when you're hot you're hot
this is hit well to the opposite field
smith goes back he'll have to play it
off the wall back to back hits seeger
heads for second and slides in with a
double
that was the 81st pitch
thrown by taiwan walker and now a full
count
you're walker you want this bad right
now you know you can't afford to give up
the wall
and he loses taylor and he's not happy
with ben may he tried to go with that
same splitty again this one just a
little in off the plate so rojas comes
to get him too bad that he couldn't
finish the ending he'll still walk off
to a very appreciative ovation allowed
only two heads through six and two
thirds but will smith's homer ties it
three and one
barking from the dugout ben may doesn't
like it rojas comes out to discuss it
see rojas saying who did you throw out
who did you throw out rojas is heading
for the tunnel this is when it's great
to be in city field the energy is up
when you're blinking horn right here you
just want to come through you want to
get this crowd up on their feet
and blankenhorn is caught looking
10 for bueller that's what you have
nightmares about right there that pitch
right there luis rojas couldn't quite
get taiwan walker through seven dave
roberts hoping he can do it here with
walker bueller and a pop wide of third
let's see if it stays in
it will
will smith grabs it
smith from his catcher's position was
able to grab it alongside the railing
the mets leave two we go to the eighth
and it's still a one-one game
coming in tonight bellinger trying to
find his groove
hit hard and by the diving alonso fair
ball down the line the dodgers take the
lead bellinger on his way to second it's
fumbled in right field but he slides
into second base and no further advance
now that has to feel good for billy
right there
and turner strikes out so the dodgers
settle for one
and they take that slim lead vr started
the inning placed at second he remains
there with two out
bouncing ball it's fair who holds just
into the game shovels it over to canable
and that finishes the ball game
the dodgers take the first two both in
10 innings